- So what you can
get on podcast.
This guy is such a
wealth of information.
His media company, VaynerMedia,
is probably the hottest company
out there in the world
of digital marketing.
We are so excited to have
him with us today,
ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Gary Vaynerchuk.
(bright music)
- Thank you.
(applause and cheers)
By show of hands,
how many people here have
no idea who I am? Raise it.
(laughter)
Yup, that hurts.
So with all those
accolades and all the things
that go on I was aware of that
situation so what I'm gonna do
for the first 10 minutes here
is give you a little background.
I apologize to those who've seen
it a few times but I think it
matters because so many of you
don't know who I am and I think
the biggest thing that matters
to me is to create context with
you because once you understand
where I come from, how I got to
this moment I think it's gonna
deploy and matter to a lot
of people in this room.
And I think it maps to where
I think the opportunity is for
so many of you in the
marketplace today.
So I was born in Belarus,
in the former Soviet Union.
I came to the US
when I was three.
I lived in a studio apartment
with my family in
Queens, New York.
(cheers)
Big ups.
We were super poor.
There was eight family
members in a studio.
It was really tough.
My dad got a bunch of side jobs.
It was the late 70s for,
this is a young crew,
but the economy wasn't good.
And my dad got a job as a
stock boy in a liquor store
in Clark, New Jersey.
He eventually became the manager
of that store and we moved to
Edison, New Jersey
when he did that.
(cheers)
I like this cheering everything.
(laughter)
I can get into this.
When I moved to
Edison, I was five, six.
That's when I started my
entrepreneurial career.
When I was six years old I had
a six lemonade stand franchise
which meant I was good
enough that selling a.k.a.
manipulating my friends into
staying behind the lemonade
stands all day while I would go
around and make signs
and put them on trees.
I'll get back to
that in a minute.
I used to ride my big wheels
bike at the end of day to pick
up my cash like I was
little Tony Soprano.
(laughter)
So that was how it started.
It was good.
Actually, you know what?
I think a lot of you
would appreciate,
this is actually a
better way to go.
I always tell the story as that
being my first business 'cause
the truth is I'm actually
embarrassed of the first
business that I ever really
did have but six months prior to
that business I started a
separate business which was
I went in to people's yards
I ripped their flowers out of
their yard I rang their doorbell
and I sold it back to them.
(laughter)
Great margin.
And the reason I wanted
to tell you this story is
I'm about to get an on the back
end of this talk into a lot of
warm and fuzzy feelings,
a lot of community, a lot of
technology but I want to make
sure everybody knows that
I'm very grounded in being a
salesman and a businessman but
I think there's a good way to
do it in a bad way to do it.
I think it's a bad way to rip
people's flowers out and
sell it to them.
I think I got better along the
way and I think I continue to
get better and to be very honest
in the competitive landscape
that so many of you play in
today, I actually do believe the
good marketing and selling
has become disproportionally
valuable in a sea of bad and
it is the separating point.
The problem is is that 95% of
this audience and look, this is
where I start getting unpopular,
I did a lot of homework before
I came to this talk because
I knew it'd be a lot of people.
I was excited about it.
So been doing some homework over
the last three or four
months actually.
Following the hashtags,
following your social media
presence and truth is punchline
is I think 95% of the people here
are just not working hard enough.
I think a lot of people
like to cry about stuff.
(applause and cheers)
Oh, Facebook changed
the algorithm on you.
Tough.
It's the market.
That's what happens.
We'll get to that in a minute.
My entrepreneurial career took a
great shift when
I was 12 and 13.
When I was 12, 13 I was selling
baseball cards in all the
malls of New Jersey.
For all the 35 to 45-year-old
males probably in this room you
might remember big,
big deal back then.
It was the, it was the
Pokémon GO of that moment.
And it was great and listen
when you're making two to
$3000 a weekend and you're
14 years old and you're putting,
you know, $25,000 in cash under
your bed and you're not selling
weed you're doing a good job.
(laughter)
So that was probably,
my goal in life is to buy the
New York Jets which is gonna
cost me several billions of
dollars but I do believe that
the richest I will ever be in my
life is when I had $25,000 when
I was 14 because you just don't
know what to do
with all that money.
And so, that was great and
then my dad ruined my life.
At this point my dad, very
much my hero with my mom.
I am perfectly parented, a new
book that I'm writing how to
raise an entrepreneur.
My dad ruined my life
I was making $2000,
$3000 a weekend, my own boss.
Living large and turned 14 and
oldest son, immigrant family
born in the old country.
My dad now has a small liquor
store in Springfield, New Jersey
as he saved up all his
money and worked hard.
He drags me into the business
and he pays me two bucks an hour
to bag ice for 15 hours a day.
How many people here by show
of hands saw the movie
"The Goonies"?
(cheers and applause)
Great.
So for two years of my life,
every weekend, every summer
vacation and I mean all of them.
How many of you remember the
last day of school you would
have a half day?
Recall, right?
My parents were so gangster they
would pick me up on my half day
of the last school and
drive me to the store to work.
Like zero days,
zero vacation days.
I would work all the time
and for two of those years the
reason I referenced
"The Goonies" basically I was
chained to the basement of my
dad's liquor store
like I was Sloth.
(laughter)
Finally, I turned 16.
I was allowed upstairs.
(laughter)
And something
very interesting happened.
It was the early, early-ish 90s,
I start realizing people
were getting into wine.
And Wine Library was
what I had in mind.
What happened was
my dad's store,
Shoppers Discount Liquors,
was in an affluent area
of New Jersey so people were
coming and asking for wine even
though we sold beer and liquor.
And finally somewhere around
when I was 16 six months in to
being upstairs somebody came in
and asked for a bottle of wine.
Then somebody else came in and
asked for that bottle of wine.
Finally, the fourth
guy came and I said,
"What's going on with this
Caymus Cabernet?"
He said, "It was just named
"the wine of the year by the
Wine Spectator."
I said, "Okay," people kept
coming in we were sold out.
Coming in, finally 20
people have come in.
They're all coming in, we
don't have it, they're leaving.
Seems like a bad business model.
I say to myself, "You know what?
"The next person that comes in
I'm gonna take a back order."
Right?
We don't have a back order
system but I go to school on
Monday anyway and
I won't have to deal with it.
(laughter)
Guy comes in goes,
"Do you have the Caymus Cab?"
I go, "No but I'll
take a backorder."
He goes, "Great," name,
address, phone number.
I go, "How many
bottles would you like?"
He said, "I'll take six
cases if you can get it."
I said, "Whoa, an alcoholic."
(laughter)
I said, "Six cases?"
He goes, "Yeah," he
goes, "I collect wine."
And that was it.
It's, you know, I love you guys
like smell something or hear a
song but you can be
brought right back to a moment.
Literally, telling you the
story, remembering how that guy
said it, I remember what
I felt in my heart
which was the following.
At that point, even at 16 years
old, because of all of my
success I thought I could run
the business better than my dad
as any good punk
entrepreneur kid should but
I wasn't interested in selling
Budweiser or
Coors Light or Absolut.
I wasn't interested and I was
sad 'cause I wanted to help
because I was so thankful and
grateful of, by the way real
quick, how many people are in
this room are an immigrant or
children of immigrants?
(light cheers and applause)
It is such an
advantage because
I remember feeling so thankful
to be able to be in this
amazing country.
I was born, I'm a
businessman, right?
I'm an entrepreneur.
I was born in the worst place in
the world for that,
Soviet Russia,
and I came to
the best place for that.
So I remember I felt guilty.
I wanted to give back to my
family business but I wasn't
interested and at that moment
I remember thinking,
"Oh my God, Ken Griffey, Jr.,
"Michael Jordan, Frank Thomas.
"Caymus, Opus One,
Château Lafitte.
"Same crap."
And so, basically I deployed
all my passion of learning
everything about sports into
learning everything about wine
and no 17 year old on earth
should know as much as I did
about Pinot Noir and Sancerre
and that's because I had
one huge advantage.
How many people are
parents in this room?
(light cheering)
I want you to pay very close
attention to what
I'm about to say.
My big advantage was
I was a D and F student.
I was a D and F student and that
was very weird because if you're
an immigrant in this room
you know that when you come to
America everything that you're
taught is education is the way
out of our poverty. Right?
But I was a D and F
student and I mean D's and F's.
Most people don't believe me
anymore because of my success.
So much so that I have my
assistant last week reach out to
my high school, I'm getting my
report cards and I'll be posting
them on Instagram for you
in the next couple of weeks.
(cheers and applause)
Real D's and F's and
again, if you're my
age group, a lot
of you are younger.
You're lucky, right now, as
a lot of you know, being an
entrepreneur is cool.
I take selfies.
It's a trend.
People care when in the 90s it
wasn't and school was the way
out and so my D's and F's
made my teachers and my friends'
parents think that
I was going to lose.
That I was a losing player and
so it's so interesting to me
that the reason I know I'm
successful was somewhere around
fifth grade I realized I did
not give a crap about Saturn.
(laughter)
Algebra wasn't
gonna do it for me.
And so what I did was I deployed
and honed my skills at 12, 13,
14, 15, 16, 17 so by the time
I fell in love with the notion
of what that was going to be
that was already
ingrained in me.
I thought I was gonna open up
8000 wine and liquor stores,
the Toys "R" Us of wine,
sell the franchise,
buy the New York Jets.
Here's where the story
starts getting relevant to you.
I go to college, I'm playing
Madden '95 in my dorm room,
dominating by the way,
my friend runs in and he says,
"You have to come and see this."
I finish my game, I walk into
the room and there are eight
18-year-old dudes
hanging around a computer.
Now for a lot of youngsters
in this room, you don't recall
this, I was 18 years old at this
point and probably spent less
than three hours on a
computer in my life.
By being a D and F student and
getting an F in computer class
I was able to stay
off the computer. Right?
(laughter)
This is 1994,
I go in this dorm room.
There's eight guys
hovering around a computer.
I hear for the first time in my
life (mimicking dial-up
modem sounds).
(laughter)
'Member that?
My friend signs on I say
some profound thing like,
"Is this the information
superhighway?"
(laughter)
My friends load up
an AOL chat room.
They type in ASL.
(laughter)
There some
35-year-olds in here.
(laughter)
That was a snap back in the day.
We talk to make pretend
girls for five hours.
(laughter)
We were for three of those
hours make pretend
girls ourselves.
(laughter)
We're doing our thing,
I literally get my turn.
We're like hanging out, like for
the youngsters in here, we hung
out and watched
people on the internet.
I got my turn.
I get on there in eight minutes
somehow I end up on a message
bulletin board in AOL that's
selling and buying
baseball cards.
In 14 minutes
I make a transaction.
Within 20 minutes of ever being
on the internet, I said,
"My God, I don't need to
open up 8000 stores.
"I'm gonna do
something on this."
18 months later I launched one
of the first three e-commerce
wine businesses in
America called WineLibrary.com.
(applause and cheers)
Don't clap.
Here's why: the first
18 months that that site ran,
that site cost $15,000 to build.
We were small family business.
$15,000 to build that website,
in the first 18 months,
'cause I was still at school,
I wasn't fully
back at the liquor store,
in the first 18 months on that
$15,000 investment in 1996, '7,
'8 internet world where most
people still weren't on it that
$15,000 investment
brought back $480 in sales.
(laughter)
I don't know how many
of you have a Soviet father--
(laughter)
but Sasha Vaynerchuk
was not happy with the ROI.
(laughter)
It was one of the more important
lessons I've learned
in business.
The disproportional reason so
many people in here will not
win, let's just get right to
the chase, the disproportionate
reason that most people in this
room will not win is actually
not the hard work which is what
I'm gonna talk about probably
for next 45 minutes.
It's your lack of patience.
(applause)
For some unknown
reason when people go into
ventures like this and other
things they somehow miraculously
think it's going to
happen in five minutes.
That you're the one person in
the world, whatever you guys
call your big club and put
posters of each other up on you
think you're going to be in that
circle in five minutes for some
reason 'cause you're the most
charismatic, you figured out
some weird
system, you've got it.
And the lack of patience is what
hurts so many people and so by
losing so much money in those
first 18 months, I had walking
into a system that
I had to be patient.
I had to build.
I had to work from 22 to 30
years old for eight years in my
20s I worked 15 hours a day,
seven days a week in my
dad's liquor store.
Today, with all things that
happened to me, I get emails on
Facebook from friends I went to
high school with often starting
with, "Gary, you're so lucky."
I reply to every
single one of them.
All of them with the reply
of an opening line first,
"Jan, great to see you again.
You look great.
"Kid's super cute.
"P.S. I am super not lucky.
"Let me remind you, Rick,
remember when we graduated
"college and you went to the
Jersey Shore every weekend and
"hooked up with
chicks and drank beer.
"I worked."
(cheers and applause)
"Rick!"
(laughter)
In those 15, 18 hours
a day out of school I grew my
dad's business from a three to a
$60 million business which meant
I was 27 years old running a
$60 million business and I was
paying myself $54,000 a year.
You know why?
'Cause I'm patient.
Because I don't
need a cool watch.
I don't a fat whip.
I want to build something
and one of the other biggest
things that pisses me off about
everybody that's been crying
about the Facebook feed.
Let me tell you what happened
when the Facebook feed changed.
The single, follow me here,
the single greatest advertising
product in the last
50 years was built.
But instead of taking a thousand
of the $6000 you've made doing
this buying and Facebook ads
with it and then making
$12,000, you cried.
Thank you, have a nice night.
(laughter)
Let me tell you how
I built that business and
what I want you to get out of
this talk that brings you value.
The only thing that we are all
connected by no matter what you
do for living inside of this
game, other games,
if you go on to something else.
You start a shoe company
remember this if you remember
anything from this talk this is
how you will win, I'm convinced
it's been the same
game for everybody.
Patience, hard work,
talent matters.
Nobody's gonna watch your
lifestream if you suck crap.
(laughter)
All those things matter.
All those things matter,
however, this is the one thing
that is my religion in the
game that I play that brings
disproportionate value which is
the following: remember the one
thing that connects all of us,
the one thing that binds us all
what you do for living, your
relatives, your friends, you can
all Kumbaya
around this one thing.
The only thing we all want
and fight for is
somebody's attention.
We all have to get your
attention before you tell me how
great your system's gonna work
or how awesome and delicious
your product is or how great
your abs are before you do any
of that you need my attention.
And what I do for living
is I day trade attention.
I follow attention and the funny
thing about that game is you
can't be romantic about where
you want the attention to be.
You just have to reverse
engineer where it actually is.
Let me explain.
In 1997, when I launched
WineLibrary.com, I went on a
mission to collect every single
person's email that ever walked
into that liquor store.
And if I was out about at a
baseball game, I asked for
business cards and I want your
email and all and every day all
I cared about in the world was
getting somebody's email to put
them on
Wine Library's email service.
In 1998, I had 150,000
people on an email newsletter.
How many people here have done
email marketing in their career?
Raise your hands.
Hi, quite a few.
Good, listen to what
I'm about to tell you.
In 1997, I had 150,000 people on
my email newsletter
that had 91% open rates.
Just to let everybody
understand, right now, if you're
in the 30s you're a hero but it
wasn't because I was so great in
1997, that my content was so
great, it was that nobody else
was doing email marketing.
I understood where the attention
was and I understood
that it was underpriced.
While other people did direct
mail and billboards and radio
and did catalogs to your house,
I understood that
email was emerging.
I was going to gather.
How many people had email
back in 1998, 1999, 2000?
Raise your hands.
So for youngsters, watch this.
Do you remember how we
treated email in 1998?
We read every single email and
every word like it
was a god damn letter.
(laughter)
And because I had
that attention,
I was able to
build a very big business.
Then I moved on.
There something called Google.
I looked at it, I saw this new
ad product where if you searched
for a wine you
could buy the first result,
that was insane to me.
I thought that was incredible
and so I bought the word wine
and many other words like
Cabernet and Pinot Noir the day
Google Adwords started.
How many people here have done
Google Adwords in her career?
Very nice.
I owned the word wine the day
Google Adwords started for five
cents a click for nine months
before anybody bid me up.
And that worked.
And I kept going and then my
career took a massive change
that I think will really impact
a lot of people in this room
if you follow this blueprint.
There was a new website out that
I was intrigued by
it was called YouTube.
Everybody in the world was
really not ready for
online video.
It hadn't happened yet.
I'd been wanting to
like play in that space.
I finally saw the site YouTube.
It was couple months old.
There's not a single video on
YouTube that
had a million views yet.
Period, on the whole platform.
So seven months
after YouTube came out,
I started Wine Library TV
which is the first time I was
doing content not advertising
and the premise of the
show was very simple.
I sat at my desk with four
bottles of wine and I had
somebody videotape me drinking
it for 20 straight minutes.
(laughter)
It was a great gig.
And somehow a year later
hundreds of thousands of people
watched me taste wine and give
my thoughts and what I did was
I understood the wine
business at that point.
I understood my
craft at that point.
How many people here have a
friend or relative that is
fairly into wine?
Raise your hands.
So you guys know exactly
what I know which is the second
somebody gets just a little bit
of wine knowledge they become a
straight jerk off.
(laughter)
You're drinking the wrong year.
Shut up.
So what I did was, by knowing
that, I talked to people about
wine instead of down to them.
I talked about wine the way it
actually smelled and taste to me
instead of the words on
the back of the label.
I called wines, you know, this
reminds me of what a racquetball
smells like when you
first open the container or
if I ate an entire pack
of Big League Chew
and swallowed it
this is what this tastes like
or when it didn't go as well if
you're at a farm and a
sheep farted in your face,
this is what this
wine tastes like.
(laughter)
What I'm about to tell
you and I'm noticing some
people are in to notes this is
a very important moment of this
talk when I asked my stock guy
to go to Best Buy to buy the
camera for Wine Library TV while
he went to the store and was
coming back what I thought
I was about to sit down and do
in February 2006 was
build the QVC of wine.
I was gonna be on camera and
I was gonna sell you wine.
And then the first
episode happened.
Literally the first one.
The light goes on and because
I understood where the internet
was going, I realized, my God,
this is going to be
online forever.
And this is gonna work.
And I'm gonna get big and if
I go to a party and somebody
says what do you think about
this wine and I taste it and I'm
like terrible and they go but
you said it was awesome on
Wine Library TV,
I could be crushed.
And so, from the first episode
of Wine Library TV,
I separated the
content from the business.
In fact, I had so many hard-core
fans, one kid at MIT who loves
math and data mapped my rating
on every wine on that show and
on that show over a thousand
episodes that I did over
5 1/2 years I paned
71% of the wines that
were on that show.
Wines that I was selling in my
store I was telling you not to
buy because I realized it was
better off for me to become
America's wine guy then it was
for me to sell you an extra
case of Pinot Noir.
(applause)
The reason I want a lot
of you to pay attention to
this because over the last
week as I've been looking at the
Instagram hashtags for BeachBody
and this summit and things of
that nature when I've gone
down the rabbit hole of your
Instagram accounts and your
Facebook fan pages that is not
the percentage of what
people are putting out there.
The majority of it is what
I would call a right hook.
I wrote a book called
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
Give, give, give and then ask.
Put out content that actually
brings value but don't be scared
to ask, you know, the funny
thing is you would think based
on the tone that I'm talking
right now that I wrote the book
to get people to
throw more jabs.
Ironically, I wrote the book
because I saw a lot of people in
2008, '9, '10, '11, '12 do a
good job on social media but not
know how to ask
for the business.
They were just
putting out content.
Lot of people email me,
they're struggling,
I look like I'm like
what's wrong?
It's so good and
I'm like wait a minute,
have they not
asked for the business?
It's very appropriate to
have people sign up,
buy as long as you can
provide so much value
that you basically guilt
them into buying.
Basically, my entire life is
predicated on providing so much
value that I guilt you into
buying my stuff but even more
importantly 'cause already good,
I just kinda want you to come to
my funeral, right?
And when you think about that
and when you make that your
strategy you go into
a different place.
Wine Library TV
changed my career.
YouTube sells for $2 billion.
I freak out and go Jesus I've
been right about everything
where consumers are going.
This has to be bigger then just
selling a couple more cases of
Pinot Noir and that's when
I decided that I would
invest in companies.
I said the next time I feel
something like E-com or email or
Google AdWords or
YouTube I'm gonna invest.
I went to SXSW 2007,
everybody was talking
about this app called Twitter.
Everybody thought was the
stupidest thing of all time
because who cares if you're
walking the dog or eating pizza.
I thought it was
the future of email.
I invested in Twitter.
I made a video about it.
Facebook saw it,
I spoke at Facebook.
I became friends with Zucks.
I invested in Facebook and then
I saw a bunch of high school
kids playing on Tumblr
and I invested in Tumblr.
I'm rich.
(laughter)
But why I tell you
that story is
that's when my
career started take,
I'm telling that story
because I wanted to brag.
But I'm telling you that story
because that's what my career
starts and my God what
I do is day trade attention.
Now I'm gonna make this
talk very valuable to you.
I'm to go through everything
that I know you're going through
platform by platform and
I'm gonna give
you really good advice.
I run a company right
now called VaynerMedia.
We're $100 million a year
strategy and creative
and media agency.
We have Under Armour and Toyota
and Dove and Budweiser and the
biggest brands in the world
paying us to sell
stuff on the internet.
Let's start with a couple
things that you need to know.
Social media, it doesn't
exist it's a slang term.
Social media is the slang term
for the current
state of the internet.
If you're sitting in this crowd
and still not devoted to these
platforms, you will lose because
the only thing that people care
about in marketing and sales
that are smart and
successful is attention.
And if you don't realize that
everybody's attention is now in
their phone you are not
paying attention to society.
How many people in this room, in
this arena, how many people in
this arena are always within
arms reach of their cell phone
in every 24 hour window?
Look around.
Keep 'em up.
Look at this.
We're becoming robots.
We'll get into that later.
(laughter)
Over 50% of everybody's
time in the world
on a phone is spent
on a social network.
Besides the games you're playing
maybe Pokémon GO's
changed that a little bit.
Besides the games you're playing
and the things of that nature,
this is where we live and for
you to sit in this audience and
disrespect Facebook, Snapchat,
Instagram, Tumblr, Pinterest all
these platforms is
an insane thing.
More importantly,
it's just beginning.
Everything we know, everything
we play in didn't
exist 10 years ago.
How many people here are
retiring within
the next 10 years?
And I don't mean you're
gonna crush it
and go live on an island.
(laughter)
I mean you're
old and you're finished.
(laughter)
My man, you still
look good though.
I'll come and fish with you.
This dude gets a pass for
the rest of you, you have to
understand we are just starting.
This is the biggest
communication shift in our
society since the
printing press.
You have 50-year-old men sitting
in this audience right now who
texted a poop emoji last night.
(laughter)
What happens, you have
to understand, is that when
these platforms are formed
we aged down our society.
How many people in this room
said they would never be on
Snapchat and now are?
Don't lie, lying is the devil.
Look at the hands.
I want people to look round.
Actually, you know what?
Stand up.
Let's do this right now.
Stand up, right now, stand up.
Don't get lazy on me.
You're supposed to be athletic.
Stand up, stand up
right now if you not
generally if you, if you
said you would never be on
Snapchat and you now are,
stand up.
If you didn't do that,
sit back down.
I need you to look
around this room.
I need to look around this
room before everybody sits down
because this is basically my
entire keynote in visual form.
I am going to buy the
New York Jets on one thesis:
I'm going to invest
time and money in the
places that you say that you're
not going to be that
I know you're going to be in.
You can sit down.
Next year 50% more of this
audience will be
on that platform.
There is so much opportunity
going on and what happens is did
I cry when my email newsletter
went from 91% to
30% over a decade?
No, I did not.
Did I cry that I spent
seven years building my Twitter
following to 1.3 million
followers by, as many of you
know, how many people here have
I replied to on social media?
Raise your hands.
One by one by one
by one and engaging.
Did I cry that when I had 5000
followers on Twitter and I tried
to sell a book or wine or
somebody to do something with me
that I can get more people
when I had, let's really call it
right, when I had 50,000
followers on Twitter,
I could get more people to do
something than I can today at
1.3 million
followers on Twitter.
It's why when you roll up at
me and go I have this many
followers, I don't give a crap.
It doesn't matter how
many followers you have.
It matters how many
followers you have that care.
(applause)
You're not paying the
bills with 100,000 Instagram
followers that you
bought on eBay, jerk.
(laughter)
So, I didn't cry that
Twitter was losing its grip.
That was a big run for me.
That's where most of you
met me and understood me.
That's where I built my brand.
It was huge for me but in 2011
and you can go watch the videos
'cause they're out, there
I was 30 pounds heavier and
pretty angry that
Twitter was going away.
I could taste it.
The attention was slipping.
Even though I had 700,000,
1.1 million followers
I was losing it.
I could tell and so I made
investments in where I thought
the platforms were going.
Some worked.
Instagram, Snapchat.
Some didn't Vine, SocialCam but
the one thing I wasn't crippled
by was putting in the work.
The one thing I wasn't crippled
And let me tell you the part of
the work that I put in that
I think a lot of you
need to consider.
On the flight here this morning
I looked at the last 50 tweets
and profiles of people in
the audience right now.
On their Instagram
accounts they put out content.
15 people comment.
11 people comment.
29 people comment.
67 people comment and of the
50 people I audited to get fresh
data for this talk not one,
goose egg, 00, Robert Parish,
not one, not one of the 50
people in this audience
engaged to one of the
people that left a comment.
Not one follow-up.
Zero because we've become, in
a social media world, pushers.
We talk but we don't listen and
that is where all the action is.
If you take one different tact
from this talk and I'm doing
this selfishly 'cause I want
you to email me in a year 'cause
you're gonna make more money.
And I want you to say thanks.
If you do one tactical thing,
we're talking theory,
I'm giving you tactical.
Do me a favor instead of going
on a 20 week ab program or you
want to get your butt up and
squat or whatever instead of
that program do my program
reply to every
single person that
leaves a comment on any social
media that you put out for one
year and watch the money grow.
Do that plan.
(applause)
Problem is that takes work.
Problem is to win you've gotta
stop watching entire seasons of
"House of Cards."
(laughter)
That is the variable but
the attention is there.
Crying about Facebook, let me
tell you about 50 people that
jumped on Snapchat in January
and are making 10 times the
money in whatever game
they're playing because they're
arbitraging Snapchat
while Facebook's going three.
Crying about Facebook, be a
business and not be an income
eater instead of buying a nice
thing with the money you make
from this, why don't you take
that money and deploy it against
Facebook ads because the word
wine was five cents a click when
I started and now
it's nine bucks.
And a three bucks it was good
and at seven bucks it wasn't as
we sit in this arena today right
this minute the number one way
that I would build every one of
your businesses is Facebook ads.
I love Snapchat.
I love Instagram.
I love a lot of things.
The number one guaranteed way
for every single person in this
room to make more
money is Facebook ads.
The problem is a lot of people
in here are headline readers
and not practitioners.
You have opinions of Facebook
ads but you never really run a
campaign at scale and so
that to me is fascinating.
And, by the way, you know when
I do these come talks especially
in a big room like this, I'm
not gonna be able to answer
follow-up questions,
everybody always asks
me, "Okay, Gary you got me.
"You were so great energy.
"You're super handsome and I'm
super pumped and I really want
"to do this and
so what do I do?"
So I'm gonna tell you what to do
off of anything you hear from me
in headline and you want to go
get the details like again,
and I'm gonna pound it into
your face until you succumb,
Facebook ads will make you a
lot more money if you deploy the
ads and if you learn it which
means 27 to 30-year-old males
that live in Omaha, Nebraska
that are into fitness.
There's a lot of skip,
Omaha, what up?
(laughter and cheers)
Whatever you decide to target,
I feel like just randomly say
Las Vegas, Nevada,--
(cheers)
Chattanooga, Tennessee--
Chattanooga is like,
"Us?"
(laughter)
"Can't believe
he said that."
Facebook ads,
Facebook ads, Facebook ads.
Let me tell you the one thing
that you need to do off of this
talk if I talk 'cause when
I get in to other things like
Musical.ly and other places and
you're gonna be what
the hell is he talking about?
There's a site you should go to
after you hear things from me if
you want to get more
deeper information on it.
I'll let you get your pens it's
G-O-
O-G-L-E,
Google.
Do you know how many of you piss
me off so much when you come up
to me and say, "Gary but I don't
know how to run Instagram ads."
Figure it out, Peter.
(laughter)
Like what's the
matter with you guys?
"Gary, I didn't grow up
with this social media stuff.
"I don't know what to do."
Hey Rick, you didn't grow up
driving, you figured it out.
(laughter)
And so what does this is
all really come down to?
It's very, very basic if you
look at every business that is
ever succeeded, every single one
of them, there are
couple of core principles.
First of all, your product.
If your product sucks the
greatest marketing in the
world will not fix it. Right?
You guys in this model are not
in charge of that so we need to
move to the next thing.
Let's assume that's in place
sure seems that way, right?
Let's go to the next place.
Attention.
You have to know where it is
and preferably you need to know
where it's underpriced.
Do Instagram advertising four
years ago when taking a picture
your butt and abs worked
good 'cause less people did it.
Now everybody does it,
doesn't work as much.
When it's every third photo on
Instagram you're
not going to stand out.
It's not gonna work.
You may, it may work for people
that like to look at it but
they're probably not gonna buy
your stuff and so understanding
where attention is
and then trading it.
To me, right now,
the greatest deals in order:
Facebook ads, I'm sorry the
organic reach went away.
Let me just give
you a punchline.
No advertising is free.
Tell me where the alternative?
What are you gonna call your
local TV station and they're
gonna run your
commercial for free?
What you call the Chattanooga
Press and they're gonna put a
full-page ad for you and
your service for free?
For the people that did Google
Adwords you guys think you've
been hurt by the
Facebook algorithm.
Go talk to the homies in digital
marketing that used to rely only
on Google when Google would
change their algorithm and
people lose $1 million overnight
and go from the first page
result of diet to page
97 and have nothing.
So that's not that hard-core.
The other thing,
Facebook, Facebook ads.
Number two best deal in the
market, Instagram influencers.
You may think of yourself
that way and that's great.
You may have a good following
but so do a ton of other people
and you can email them.
They all love to put their
Gmail in their Instagram profile
because they can't wait for you
to call them and
offer them some money.
Sponsored content through
influencers is an
extremely strong arbitrage.
Again, it is my great belief
because I've spoken to so many
and I've watched so many and
I paid attention, we're not
investing in our business.
We want our time and our content
to drive our business but when
we get the money, we
want to go buy stuff.
We want to go put in the corner.
We don't put it back into our
business and that is the grave
mistake of so many of
you in this room today.
So whether you deploy
that against Facebook ads or
Instagram influencers both are
under enormous arbitrages that
can build your business.
Because remember the content is
the variable, but you have your
story, right, other
people have their stories.
The number one thing you
shouldn't do is make up your
story 'cause
that's how you lose.
So you need other stories.
You've gotta figure
that out, got it?
Next, Snapchat.
Telling you guys right now,
you know,
in 2012, '13 there's a
video I have online where
I yell at the audience and
I say, "You're all gonna be on
"Snapchat you just
don't realize it," and
I believed it and I believed it
and obviously a lot of people
probably remember in November,
December, January of this last
year and into this year the
DJ Khaled phenomenon happened.
Brought a lot more awareness.
Over the last six months it is
gotten so much older where as
everybody thought it was
like sexting for 15-year-olds.
I think everybody now
understands it's not.
And exactly what happened in
Facebook I used to go and talk
in 2006 and '07 say Facebook,
Facebook, Facebook and
everyone's like,
"That's college,"
and I was like,
"You don't understand."
When an entire generation of
people take on a platform as
they age up and their lives
change they drag people down.
I called it at the time
in 2007 the grandma rule.
I felt that when the kids of
Facebook, the early 20s, would
start having children and put
their pictures on Facebook that
grandma was gonna
sign up for Facebook.
It's happening faster now.
Do you know what fastest growing
category on Instagram of people
that take selfies are?
40 to 50-year-old women.
Cougars selfies.
(laughter)
The way we are eating,
the way we workout,
the way we dress,
everybody in here right now,
if you can think
of how old you are
if you're lucky
enough to have known your
parents at the age you are right
now and you can think about them
you were dramatically younger in
your behavior and appearance and
the way you roll.
That's what's happening.
Technology is bringing us down.
Down the age down-ification.
And my friends, the stakes are
high with what I'm talking about
because what is really exciting
is the next 10 years the
Snapchat, Facebooks, these,
how many people
familiar with Musical.ly?
Which means you have an 8 to
14-year-old girl in your life.
These things are popping up.
There's opportunities.
There's a real opportunity.
Who's gonna be the first 20
people here to figure out what
old people do on Musical.ly?
I'm trying to figure it out
because the attention's there
and there's opportunity.
But no you debate
dumb things like,
"Is it a fad? Will Snapchat be
here in two years?"
Who gives a crap, it's here now.
Nobody cares when the number one
show on TV "Empire" or
"American Idol" is number one
they run commercials during it
and if it's canceled
three years later
who cares you run it
somewhere else.
While you sit and debate is
Snapchat gonna be here or how
long or or what to do on it
while you sit and ponder your
squandering real money.
Real money.
So here we are
halfway through the year,
Facebook changed
their algorithm.
A lot of you relied on that.
The world a lot of people in the
world relied on that and what
they've done for the first six
months of this year is
couple different things.
Strategy number one, complain.
Strategy number two,
(holds breath)
"They have to change it back,
we're all gonna leave."
Yeah.
(laughter)
Instead of figuring out
the ad product, instead of
investing in what's going on in
Snapchat, instead of trying to
create video content on
Periscope or Facebook Live.
Either you're on the offense
or your on the defense and you
gotta make that decision as
you sit here today which part of
this game are you going be on.
Because what you have to
understand is the attention of
the end consumer is
shifting faster and faster.
$90 billion spent on television
commercials by my clients at
Budweiser, Dove, Toyota, all
these platforms, right?
Follow me here because this is
gonna get really
important to you.
'Cause a lot people are like,
"Who cares, that's different?"
It's very different.
They spent a lot of
money on television.
Watch this.
By show of hands, how many of
you in this audience now when
you watch TV,
outside of live sports,
watch it on your time
not when it actually airs?
Through Netflix, HBO Go,
DVR, TiVo, raise your hands.
Oh weird, everybody.
And how many of you fast-forward
every single commercial when
given the chance?
Oh weird, everybody.
And even if you're lucky enough
from the advertiser standpoint
to get a commercial in front of
you for let's say I don't know
you dropped the remote
control off your bed.
(laughter)
Let's say if there even that
lucky, even if they're that
lucky, the second a commercial
gets on you grab your cell phone
and you check your work, you
look at your social, you do not
give attention to
what you're watching.
Attention,
commercials aren't dead.
People watch TV.
People don't consume
television commercials.
Got it?
And then what really makes me
angry with you guys and when
I say "you guys"
I don't mean you.
I mean everybody on Earth.
(laughter)
Is you do things as a
businesswoman and man that is in
your best interest but then
you as a human when you live you
would never succumb to that.
You would never
click a banner ad.
You don't want to bull crap
social media ad either but you
do it because that's what you
want to happen on your end but
as a user you would never do
that and in that balance is
where all the magic is.
Why does the TV numbers
that we just saw matter?
Why does the following to,
guys, do you know that billboard
prices are up 15% in
the last five years.
Billboards, outside
billboards, right?
Meanwhile every person here when
they're the passenger in a car
is looking at their phone.
Nobody's looking at billboards.
Just common sense, billboards
are not as, as a matter of fact
by the way, real quick, when you
leave this conference
do me one favor.
Look at five people driving when
you get to the
airport and go home.
Just look into five cars,
I promise you the following:
every passenger is
looking at their phone and
three out of the five drivers
are looking at their phone.
You guys have scared me so much.
I've been doing this for
marketing, I'm now driving with
two hands again
for the first time
'cause I don't trust you jerks.
(laughter)
My friends people
aren't looking at billboards.
They're not even looking at
the road and when we have self
driving cars, that game is over.
So where is the billions of
dollars from billboards going?
Where's the almost trillion
dollars, hundred billion dollars
of television money gonna go?
How many people here can't wait
to leave this conference go home
get to their mailbox and
carefully go through
their direct mail?
You're weird, lady.
(laughter)
Tell me where those billions
of dollars are gona go?
Let me save you guys
all a lot of time.
In the next 5 to 7, 10 years
tens of billions of dollars from
the biggest companies in the
world are going to go into
these digital properties.
And the word wine goes from
five cents a click to 10 bucks.
And a Facebook ad that I was
running 24 months ago the cost
me $0.50 to reach a thousand
people is now
costing me four bucks.
And right now you can compete
with yourselves in that world
but when Coca-Cola comes and
when Toyota comes and when the
NFL comes, your numbers
are not to be as good.
You're gonna be paying $88 a
person to sign up instead of $8.
So you can either act now and
grab away or you can continue to
complain, debate, ponder and not
educate yourself for you to be a
self serving coach entrepreneur
sitting in this room and have
not spent the one hour to either
read or watch a YouTube video of
how to actually place a Facebook
ad which I know, you know what,
let's do this for each other.
I'm gonna ask you something
right now you're
gonna want to do it.
How many people here,
by show of hands, have never
placed a Facebook ad?
Raise your hands.
It's gonna be, higher and how
many of those people haven't
even spent one hour in
learning how to do that?
Please tell me the
truth for each other.
It's unacceptable.
Let me rephrase, it's acceptable
if you do zero complaining and
you're super pumped.
(laughter)
If you're happy, I got
nothing for you but I'm just
very, very taken aback as
somebody who really believes
that you have to
sacrifice if you want.
Guys, think about this for five
seconds, you have the audacity
to be here today with the
ambition to live
life on your terms.
You sit here and you
have the audacity.
You're gonna be the very
small 1% of people that can live
unbelievably on your terms.
Guys, the top 1% income makers
in America, the bottom of that
number is $400,000 year.
If you make $400,000 a year you
are in the 1% of earners in this
very competitive country, right?
And that's a lot, a lot of money
but I think a lot of people
think $1 million is before
it gets good, it's crazy.
We have to reframe
entrepreneurship.
If you want $100,000 a year you
sit in this room today and you
have the audacity, I hope
you're running Facebook ads.
You sit in this room and
you have the audacity to want to
live on your terms.
To not work for anybody else.
To support your entire
livelihood on you, right?
When I hear that and I know
that you play Candy Crush
and I know that you
have Netflix on 24/7
and I know that you've been in
48 parks this weekend
trying to find Pikachu,--
(laughter)
by the way, I believe
in work life balance.
There's a lot more to life.
Family, leisure, do it, right?
But, but you want
to live on your terms.
You want to be able to do all
these great things and have all
this stuff and you don't know
how to run Facebook ads and you
haven't signed up for
a Snapchat account.
Do you understand as an
entrepreneur you benefit from
signing up for those accounts
just to learn even if it's not
successful for you.
I signed up for SocialCam,
spent lots of hours, it died.
I got nothing from it but
when Snapchat came along and
Instagram video came along,
the things I learned by creating
content on SocialCam provided me
the advantage that I needed to
make all the dollars I have.
And so, he said something
great I'll talk to you outside.
(laughter)
And so, I just genuinely,
as I wrap up here,
really want to
focus on work ethic.
You can not go home from this
trip to all the lovely places
you live and
muster up more talent.
You can get better at
what you do, right?
I'm not gonna go home and shoot
so many basketballs that
I'm gonna be in the NBA. Right?
I can become a better pickup
player but nobody here's gonna
go home and all of a
sudden become
dramatically more charismatic,
a better storyteller,
you can't go home and do that.
You can get slightly better
but your DNA is your DNA but
everybody here can go home and
work one more hour and
work two more hours.
(applause)
It's just real.
The reason I push it,
and by the way,
the whole like
immigrants do well.
It's 'cause that's what they do.
They just don't
do anything else.
When you come with nothing and
you live in crap, you just work
every God damn minute and then
all of a sudden 13 years later
something good happens.
And I just genuinely want that
for people to understand, look
yourself in the mirror in your
hotel room tonight and say,
"Are you putting in the work
that supports the words that are
"coming out your mouth?"
My buddies always tell me,
"I'm gonna be a millionaire."
I'm like, "You're on six
softball teams, John."
(laughter)
Is your work ethic mapping
the bull crap that's
coming out of your mouth?
'Cause you talk a good game.
You all talk about what you
gonna do but then the work
doesn't support it and so the
work ethic is the number one
variable because guess what
happens when you actually work
three or four or
five more hours a day?
Because you can still
sleep your six, seven hours.
You can still find an hour
or two with your family.
You can have a 9-to-5 job and
still have plenty
of hours to work.
Guess what happens?
You watch the one hour YouTube
video how to
place a Facebook ad.
You place the Facebook ads.
You look at the data.
You realize what's
working and not working.
You find your moment.
You find your segment.
You find your picture and video
and you start doing business.
You know what else happens
when you deploy five
or six more hours at work?
You reply to all the people that
say nice things about you on
your Instagram account.
You put in the work.
You know what else happens when
you were five or six
more hours a day?
You start making social media
posts that look like this which
were very successful for me,
"Post your phone number,
"I'm gonna call you
and give you value."
And then you spent five
hours talking to the people that
decided to follow you and
through a 18 minute conversation
with them they decide
to do business with you.
But when you don't put in the
five or six more hours,
you don't.
And you start relying on
things like ooh, the Facebook
algorithm's been good
for a couple of years.
And then you wake up one
morning and Zuck screws you.
(laughter)
I have no interest in
letting any platform, any move,
any business dictate my future
or my family's future and the
only way I know how to do that--
(applause)
and the only way that
I know how to do that is to
fundamentally out work every
single person in here.
The work ethic matters.
It's the part you
don't want to hear.
It's no different than the
ad he just showed, right?
No.
No, there's no system.
No, you're gonna have some
amazing Facebook post that's
gonna getting all these people
into your tree and then they're
gonna do the work and
you're gonna be in Jamaica
laying there drinking Rumchada.
(laughter)
No, you know zero people
on Earth that have been
really successful that
haven't put in the work.
Zero, if they've
done it themselves.
If mommy and daddy gave them
a crap load of money, cool.
But anybody who's ever earned it
put in the work and we live in a
world right now and let's cut to
the chase it's been so great in
our country for so
long, we're soft.
We complain about dumb stuff.
Lots of it.
We complain, we're not grateful,
we think things are
to be handed to us.
Let me give you a punchline.
You're a minority?
You're a female entrepreneur?
Your parents sucked?
You grew up in a
bad neighborhood?
Something really bad happened
to you as a kid 'cause the
neighbor's a weird dude?
The market doesn't care.
It's not fun.
That's no fun
especially the last scenario.
People have bad things
that happen to them.
Here's the sad part,
the market doesn't care.
The market doesn't care what's
amazing about the American
business market is if you're
good enough you win no matter
what you look like.
They will buy.
It's what we do.
It's been proven over
and over and over again.
The problem also is if
something's against you,
you can't speak English
when you first come here,
duh-duh-duh-duh, the
market equally doesn't care.
It will reward you but it
will not feel bad for you.
And it will not penalize
you, which is unbelievable.
We are so, so lucky and I just
fundamentally believe that 99%
of you in this room are not
taking full advantage of it
because I'm gonna leave
you with something very weird,
do me a favor.
Do me one favor from this
talk, go to a retirement home.
I want you to go to retirement
home in the next six months and
volunteer for one day and
I want you to have
10 to 15 conversations.
I'm gonna tell you
what to look for.
It's the scariest word
I've ever heard, regret.
If you talk to 90-year-olds in a
retirement home, they will talk
to you about regret and what
they talk about is the things
they didn't do instead
of the things they did.
My friends, we are all going
to die and we got real lucky.
I don't know if you've looked
to the math but the rarity of
actually becoming a
human being is unbelievable.
I mean, you know, your mom
could've went to go get
another glass of wine.
(laughter)
The math for
that moment to happen.
You could've been a tree.
You could've been a rhino.
You could've been a rock.
You're a human and
wait a minute,
punchline, you live
in a America.
Lotto!
(applause and cheers)
Lot!